und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka gegen
abend alle welt blickt auf boris johnson
nach der niederlage die er jetzt im
parlament erlitten hat klar dass das
große aufmerksamkeit auf sich zieht wie
diese sehr spezielle premierminister
versucht seinen willen mit der
brechstange durchzusetzen
die andere nicht weniger interessante
frage ist aber was diese aktuellen
entwicklungen für großbritannien und
europa bedeuten
einiges spricht dafür dass die rexit
debatte in eine weitere verlängerung
geht einschließlich regelmäßiger besuche
britischer gesamte an brüssel
das kann zwar niemanden freuen doch die
alternative ein chaos aus tritt ohne
abkommen die schreckt noch mehr diana
zimmermann berichtet noch gibt es gar
keinen termin für wahlen aber boris
johnson hat schon mal mit dem wahlkampf
begonnen
die kulisse ist sorgfältig gewählt für
seinen auftritt als starker mann seine
botschaft auf keinen fall werde er die
vom parlament beschlossene verschiebung
des brh exit in brüssel beantragen er
die dich tot im graben
beim schlendern durch die fußgängerzone
bekommt er viel gegenwind
sie sollten in brüssel sein und
verhandeln nicht der einzige kritiker
heute am morgen hatte sein bruder joe
johnson konservativer staatssekretär im
bildungsministerium seinen rücktritt
erklärt es war eine ehre abgeordneter zu
sein und drei regierungen anzugehören
aber jetzt ist es zeit etwas neues zu
machen
der kleine johnson befürworter eines
zweiten referendums glaubt der kurs
seines acht jahre älteren bruders schade
dem nationalen interesse
ein schwerer schlag persönlich und
politisch so hat eine andere meinung zur
eu das spaltet ja auch andere familien
aber worin er mir zustimmen würde ist
dass die sache erledigt gehört
während die konservativen sich weiter
zerlegen findet die opposition zusammen
sie überlegt die von johnson ersehnten
neuwahlen so lange aufzuhalten bis die
verschiebung des brh exit gesichert ist
niemand kann diese man trauern nicht mal
seine eigene partei wir sagen wir
blockieren einen ungeordneten bei exit
beschützen die wirtschaft jobs und
unseren lebensstandard und dann haben
wir die wahlen labour kann denen nicht
mit reiner freude entgegensehen zwei
drittel der briten halten jeremy cohen
für inkompetent profitieren werden die
entschieden pro-europäischen
liberaldemokraten dass die opposition
gemeinsame sache macht ist der eine
alptraum für johnson dass die wahlen
nach einem nochmals verschobenen praxis
stattfinden könnten der andere
denn dann hätte er sein versprechen
gebrochen und es freut sich der wahre
könig der eu feindlichkeit nigel farage
mit seiner drechsel partei am montag
wird die regierung daher noch einmal
versuchen neue wein auf den 15 oktober
zulegen erwartet wird viel gegenwind
verglichen mit den problemen in
großbritannien und den tiefen riss der
in der praxis frage quer durch die
gesellschaft geht in dem ja ganze
familien zerbrechen
also verglichen damit geht es
hierzulande politisch ja fast
beschaulich zu auch wenn es sich
vielleicht nicht so anfühlt sehr
interessante ergebnisse gibt es im neuen
zdf-politbarometer dass am ende der
sendung auch noch in aller
ausführlichkeit präsentieren
demnach sieht eine große mehrheit der
bevölkerung die bundesregierung als ein
ziemlich stabiles bündnis mehr als 70
prozent der befragten glauben dass die
große koalition bis zur nächsten
bundestagswahl halten wird im juni gab
es dann noch etwas mehr unsicherheit da
sagten das nur 60 prozent
interessant auch das stimmungsbild in
der bevölkerung mit blick auf die afd
die große mehrheit insgesamt 80 prozent
der bundesbürger sehen war der afg ein
weit verbreitetes rechtsextremes
gedankengut
davon sagen 41 prozent dass
rechtsextremes gedankengut in der partei
sogar sehr weit verbreitet ist
39 prozent sehen zumindest eine weite
verbreitung
nur 14 prozent empfinden das nicht so
stark ein prozent sieht das gar nicht
die restlichen befragten machten keine
angaben und sehr bemerkenswert fällt
auch die klassische sonntagsfrage aus
wenn schon jetzt am sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre käme die union auf
28 prozent die spd auf 15
die fdp läge bei 13 prozent die fdp käme
nur noch auf 6 die linke läge bei 7 die
grünen hingegen bei 24 prozent
damit ergibt sich natürlich auch ein
spannendes bild für eine mögliche
regierungsbildung
die spd müsste nicht noch mal in eine
ungeliebte koalition mit cdu/csu
die fdp wäre übrigens ganz raus aus dem
spiel
jamaika wäre nicht mehr nötig wenn sie
wollten könnten union und grüne allein
ein stimm starkes zweierbündnis bilden
angesichts dieser perspektiven passt es
dass die union derzeit das thema
klimaschutz forciert man grüßt sich
sozusagen schon mal ein bisschen an
florian hand berichtet bis
sonnenuntergang kreisen die gedanken im
regierungsviertel täglich gerade vor
allem um ein thema und ein datum
nein ausnahmsweise kein wald sonntag
sondern freitag der 20
september tag für eine außerplanmäßige
kabinettssitzung
dann will die bundesregierung hier ihr
klimakonzept beschließen und zwar nicht
irgendeines
kein pille palle hatte die kanzlerin
intern angesagt csu-landesgruppenchef
dobrindt spricht vom lackmustest dieser
koalition und spd vizekanzler olaf
scholz verlangt ein großer wurf sei
nötig natürlich brauchen wir diesen
großen wurf wir haben uns ja so dermaßen
mit dem klimaschutz von den zielen
entfernt dass wir jetzt einfach tempo
456 einfach mal zulegen müssen das rächt
sich jetzt dass man einfach die letzten
30 jahre zwar was gemacht hat aber mit
viel viel zu langsam und tempo und das
muss man jetzt einfach nachholen
nachholen also wohl auch um grünen
wahlerfolgen etwas entgegenzusetzen
gestern und heute klausur der
unionsfraktionsspitze dazu in potsdam
heute und morgen die der spd in berlin
bei beiden ganz oben die frage nach
einem co2 preis braucht es eine neue co2
steuer die von der spd umweltministerin
vorgeschlagen merkel und die union haben
sich festgelegt und zwar dagegen
wir halten diesen zertifikatehandel also
ein handels ein marktmodell langfristig
für effizienter
es gibt leute die sagen ja das wirkt
doch nicht so schnell deswegen brauchen
wir eine co2 steuer ich glaube das
kriegt man auch innerhalb eines
zertifikate handels drin kurzfristig
unmöglich heißt es dazu in einem papier
der spd
doch nach außen gibt man sich
kompromissbereit wir werden glaube ich
gute und kluge vorschläge einbringen wo
wir am ende zu einer gemeinsamen guten
lösung kommen ein co2 preis allein macht
keinen durchbruch noch reicht er um ein
grüneres profil zu gewinnen und zu
diskutieren heute nachmittag die
staatssekretäre der regierung im
finanzministerium über ein zusätzliches
maßnahmenpaket für klimaschutz
jedes ministerium hatte intern listen
vorgelegt hier etwa die vom
landwirtschafts ressort jede maßnahme
etwa mehr ökologisch bewirtschaftete
flächen versehen mit möglichen co2
einsparungen und möglichen kosten so
langsam nämlich reift auch die
erkenntnis klimaschutz kostet um noch
teurere klimaschäden abzuwenden
doch bei der frage nach der finanzierung
heute ausweichmanöver
wir führen momentan eine sehr fixierte
diskussion darauf was kann der bund
gegen den klimawandel tun nein das ist
eine gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe ist
auch eine aufgabe der länder der
finanzminister hat gut vorgesorgt es
gibt fonds für diesen bereich aber am
ende werden wir die summe ziehen müssen
am ende eine summe ziehen müssen es sind
nicht mehr viele sonnenuntergänge bis
zum 20 september
klimaschutz geht natürlich hand in hand
mit der energiewende dazu gehört auch
die windkraft aber der scheint seit
einiger zeit die puste auszugehen
der ausbau der windenergie ist fast zum
erliegen gekommen
die bundesregierung will die branche nun
wieder in schwung bringen und dazu gab
es heute in berlin einen sogenannten
wind gipfel frage an unsere wirtschafts
fachfrau valerie haller wo liegen die
probleme also die größten probleme gibt
es beim ausbau auf dem land wo im ersten
halbjahr oft gar keine neuen anlagen
dazu gekommen sind ja woran liegts
flächen fehlen genehmigungen ziehen sich
jahrelang hin und die klagen von
umweltschützern und anwohnern blockieren
neue windräder außerdem fehlt geld weil
sich natürlich unter den aktuellen
umständen nicht gerade viele investoren
finden die in das riskante geschäft
einsteigen wollen die branche leidet
unter dieser flaute zehntausende
arbeitsplätze sind verloren gegangen ja
und wenn jobs und firmen erst mal weg
sind dann lässt sich der ausbau auch nur
schwer wieder ankurbeln und was ist da
jetzt von regierungsseite zum ankurbeln
geplant man will jetzt erarbeiten wie
mehr flächen ausgewiesen und
genehmigungen beschleunigt werden können
außerdem will man bei der bevölkerung
die akzeptanz für windräder erhöhen mit
geld bürger und kommunen sollen an
windparks nämlich beteiligt werden die
regierung wird sich auch anhalten müssen
wenn der ausbau nicht vorankommt sind
die klimaziele in gefahr unklar ist auch
ob deutschland genug eigenen strom hat
wenn die kohlekraftwerke erst mal
ausgeschaltet sind vor allem wenn
erneuerbare energien noch nicht
ausreichen und dankeschön valerie und
weiter geht's mit den nachrichten von
heinz wolf und die beginnen mit dem
schweren hurrikanen in den usa ja das
us-hurrikan-zentrum warnt weiter vor
störrischen flutwellen und enormen
regenmengen die der wirbelsturm mit sich
bringt das zentrum des hurrikans liegt
derzeit etwa 90 kilometer vor der küste
von south carolina über dem atlantik und
so sind die küstenregionen dort und in
north carolina betroffen von der
zerstörungskraft die dorian trotz
inzwischen etwas abgeschwächter wind
geschwindigkeiten nach wie vor hat zuvor
hatte der sturm auf den bahamas schwere
zerstörungen angerichtet mindestens 20
menschen sind dort ums leben gekommen
inzwischen kommt immer mehr hilfe auf
den inseln an
in italien hat die neue regierung aus
populistischer fünf sterne bewegung und
den sozialdemokraten die arbeit
aufgenommen
regierungschef konnte und seine minister
legten vor staatspräsident materieller
ihren amtseid ab neuer aussenminister
ist fünf sterne chef die mio die
sozialdemokraten stellen mit roberto
wollte er den wirtschafts und
finanzminister in der großen koalition
könnte es nach einigen unstimmigkeiten
nun eine einigung geben darüber wie es
für die bundeswehr tornado flugzeuge im
internationalen anti es kampf weiter
geht das derzeitige bundestagsmandat für
die stationierung in jordanien endet am
31 oktober
bis dahin sei ein vollständiger abzug
inzwischen nicht mehr möglich sagt der
spd-fraktionschef mützenich und zeigte
sich jetzt offen für ein neues mandat
er warf der früheren
verteidigungsministerium von der leyen
vor sie habe den abzug nicht ausreichend
mit den partnern abgesprochen
vier tage nach der landtagswahl in
brandenburg fanden heute erste
sondierungsgespräche zur bildung einer
regierung statt die spd von
ministerpräsident dietmar woidke traf
sich zuerst mit der cdu anschließend mit
der linken ihrem bisherigen
koalitionspartner
künftig braucht die spd mindestens zwei
bündnispartner um weiter regieren zu
können eine koalition mit der fdp
ausgeschlossen
in afghanistan stehen verhandlungen
zwischen den usa und taliban-vertretern
kurz vor einem abschluss
gleichzeitig versuchen radikale gruppen
der aufständischen
die gespräche durch anhaltende gewalt zu
torpedieren
heute starben bei anschlägen in kabul
und der östlichen provinz logar
mindestens 16 menschen darunter auch
zwei nato soldaten
bereits gestern wurden mindestens 33
zivilisten und sicherheitskräfte bei
gefechten getötet
der geheimdienstchef des landes trat
zurück als frankreichs präsident emanuel
makro die anderen staats und
regierungschefs beim g7-gipfel mit einem
unerwarteten besucher überraschte dem
iranischen außenminister war dass der
versuch doch noch mal bewegung in den
verhärteten atomkonflikt zu bringen
im moment sieht es aber erstmal noch
nach weitere eskalation aus die usa
haben weitere sanktionen gegen iran
verhängt und irans präsident johann ii
wiederum zieht sich aus dem historischen
atom abkommen immer weiter zurück und
kündigte an sämtliche beschränkungen für
nukleare forschung und entwicklung
aufzuheben
ja es ist für uns sie mir an iranische
verbraucher sind kummer gewohnt seit
über einem jahr wird irland wieder von
wirtschaftssanktionen gequält doch seit
einigen monaten schafft es ihre
regierung irgendwie die wechselkurse und
die preise für grundnahrungsmittel
einigermaßen stabil zu halten
ich bin kein wirtschaftsfachmann und
klar billiger wird nichts in diesem land
aber es ist gut dass die preise nicht
mehr ansteigen
um die gemüter zu besänftigen punkt
irans regierung geld ins system noch hat
das land rücklagen aber die gehen zur
neige
es muss also etwas passieren und zu
erhöht iran weiter den druck auf europa
die wirtschaftssanktionen der usa
finanziell auszugleichen
ich gebe nun den dritten schritt bekannt
sagte irans präsident gestern abend
unsere atomenergiebehörde wurde
angewiesen die nötigen technischen
schritte auf den gebieten forschung und
entwicklung einzuleiten mit dem ziel
unsere verpflichtungen aus dem atom
abkommen weiter auszusetzen
was genau damit gemeint ist soll wohl am
samstag verkündet werden vermutlich wird
es um zentrifugen für die
urananreicherung gehen das signal nach
innen wie nach außen ist klar wir geben
nicht nach so bleibt auch der von irans
revolutionsgarden vor der küste
festgehaltene britische öltanker weiter
an der kette prompt erhöhen auch die usa
den druck drohen allen die den
revolutionsgarden helfen iranisches öl
zu schmuggeln und zu verkaufen
hier netzwerk hat mit illegalen ölhandel
hunderte millionen dollar umgesetzt die
zur finanzierung von terrornetzwerken
verwendet wurden ein gutes dutzend
öltanker haben rund zehn millionen
barrels exportiert vor allem zur
unterstützung des syrischen
assad-regimes amerika zahlt eine hohe
belohnung dem der hilft solche tanker
festzusetzen
ohne öl einnahmen aber will der iran
seine verpflichtungen aus dem atom
abkommen nicht wieder einhalten so
umwirbt frankreichs präsident makro
seinen us-kollegen donnell traut der
möge die genehmigung erteilen sie um
ihre hand für rund 14 milliarden euro um
kredite zu gewähren
ein plan der weniger washington sondern
eher teheran
gut gefällt wenn die europäer unser öl
kaufen ob in bar oder als vorauszahlung
wenn sie uns also wieder zugang zu öl
einnahmen verschaffen dann würden wir
unsere verpflichtungen im atom abkommen
wieder einhalten
nach außen wird weiter gedroht hinter
den kulissen weiter gefeilscht
im moment so scheint es geht es am
persischen golf weniger um einen krieg
sondern mehr um einen deal
was sich so viele jahre lang auf den
campingplatz im nordrhein-westfälischen
lüfte abgespielt hat dürfte eine der
bislang schlimmsten fälle von
kindesmissbrauch sein der hierzulande
aufgeklärt wurde
mehr als 40 kinder hundertfach
missbraucht mit furchtbarste
grenzenloser sexueller gewalt der
richterin am landgericht fehlten heute
die worte um zu beschreiben was den
opfern angetan wurde körperlich und
seelisch hinzukam atemberaubende
ermittlungsfehler und behörden versagen
gegen die beiden hauptangeklagten wurde
heute das urteil gefällt thomas nun
berichtet zwölf jahre haft plus
sicherungsverwahrung für mario f 13
jahre haft plus sicherungsverwahrung für
andreas v auf freien fuß werden beide
wohl nach diesen urteilen nicht mehr
kommen
die angeklagten ein rückhaltloses
geständnis abgelegt die sich
strafmildernd ausgewirkt haben
strafschärfend hat sich ausgewirkt
das hat die kammer mit adjektiven wie
perfide fassungslos machen
abscheulich umschrieben dass es eben
über einen sehr langen tatzeitraum zu
dieser erheblichen zahl der taten mit
erheblichen opferzahl gekommen ist mehr
als 40 kinder sind bekannt den hier auf
dem campingplatz in lichter elbrinxen in
der baracke von andreas v schlimmste
sexuelle gewalt widerfahren ist die
dunkelziffer könnte deutlich höher
liegen in lichte wollen die meisten nur
noch abschließen mit den grausamen taten
ich finde dass das urteil gerecht ist
was heißt gerecht eigentlich müsste es
doch viel schlimmer sein oder viel höher
werden weil dafür gibt es eigentlich
keine worte was sie gemacht haben ich
denke mal dass man nur hart durchgreife
ist absolut legitim
viele schämen sich für ihre heimatstadt
obwohl sie persönlich schuldlos sind
wenn man den urlaub fährt egal wohin man
traut sich ja schon nicht mehr zu sagen
wir kommen ausflüchte geht mir sofort
auf den fall angesprochen
der leuchter bürgermeister geht einen
schritt weiter
ihm bereitet vor allem ein gedanke
sorgen
wenn so etwas in so einer ländlich
strukturierten kommunen willigte in
einer kleinen kommunen oder das leben
noch in ordnung ist und jeder jeden
kennt wohl jeder jedem hilft da passiert
ist ja dann muss man davon ausgehen dass
das wo auch immer bundesweit immer und
überall passieren können wir sind
eigentlich ja stellvertretend für die
gesellschaft einen pranger gestellt
worden
strafrechtlich ist das verfahren damit
beendet politisch geht es aber noch
lange weiter ein untersuchungsausschuss
im landtag sondern das jahrelange
versagen von jugendämtern und polizei
aufklären
innenminister wolf verspricht das
engagement dafür zu sorgen dass solche
taten verhindert werden
zumindest aber dann wenn sie passiert
sind schnellstmöglich erkannt werden und
unterbunden werden
und das wird auch in zukunft eine
vielleicht die wichtigste aufgabe meiner
amtszeit bleiben möchte eine kleine
stadt an der grenze zu niedersachsen hat
die aufmerksamkeit der politik auf ein
feld gelingt das viel zu lange im
dunkeln
und jetzt nochmal anderer meldungen
seien falsch
wenn alleinerziehende von ihren
ex-partnern keinen unterhalt für ihre
kinder bekommen springt in bestimmten
fällen der staat mit einem vorschuss 1
und kann die auslagen nur selten zurück
fordern 61 prozent der säumigen
elternteile seien finanziell nicht in
der lage das geld zurückzuzahlen geht
aus berechnungen des
familienministeriums hervor
insgesamt erhielten 2018 mehr als
800.000 kinder einen unterhaltsvorschuss
zum sport bei den us open in new york
hat das deutsche tennis doppel kevin
krawietz und andreas mies den einzug ins
finale verpasst sie verlorene halbfinal
spielen zwei sätzen gegen das team
gransee barrios
und die deutsche fußball
nationalmannschaft hat heute in hamburg
der abschluss training absolviert für
das em qualifikationsspiel morgen gegen
die niederlande verzichten muss
bundestrainer löw auf den
mittelfeldspieler leon goretzka im
hamburger volksparkstadion wollen sie
den positiven trend bestätigen
die ausverkaufte arena schauplatz der
nächsten reifeprüfung für das verjüngte
löw team das auf einen offensivstarken
gegner trifft
holland hat sie stark verbessert
fußballerisch extrem gut verbessert
gefährliche schnelle spieler
das ist schwer zu verteidigen zu mit
holland macht also von daher müssen wir
uns einstellen müssen gucken dass morgen
die konzentration hochhalten brand oder
werner werden den durch die verletzung
von sunny frei gewordenen platz im
angriff besitzen eine einsatzgarantie
bekam sabri das futur ii um ist eine der
wenigen neubauten rund um den berliner
hauptbahnhof die sofort ins auge fallen
in einer umgebung aus architektonischen
einheitsbrei ragt es ästhetisch deutlich
heraus und dürfte auch jedem
berlin-touristen sofort auffallen was
ist das es ist wenn man so will ein haus
der zukunft eine mischung aus forschungs
bühne und futuristischen technik
position
heute war flog carsten behrendt hat sich
die ausstellung für uns angesehen haben
wir menschen eine zukunft wie wird das
was werden könnte oder auch nicht das
futur ii um wagt den blick nach vorn
die große herausforderung ist einmal das
sind noch nicht vorhandene sichtbar zu
machen was man zeigen kann und das ist
ja das was wir hier auch in der
ausstellung tun ist verschiedene wege in
die zukunft zu zeigen welche
möglichkeiten gibt es denn zukunft zu
denken und auch zukunft zu gestalten
so sieht das aus was es noch nicht zu
sehen gibt architektur visionen holz
statt stahl und beton klimaneutral
der natürliche kreislauf als leitbild
keine blumen verwelken und von vorne
visualisiert als murmelbahn mit aufzug
58 millionen euro hat der bau am
berliner hauptbahnhof gekostet
hauptsächlich finanziert vom bundes
wissenschaftsministerium ein haus mit
höchster energieeffizienz solarfelder
auf dem dach die kaltluft für die
klimaanlage wird dem kerzenwachs
gespeichert zur eröffnung heute kam
besuch von ganz oben astronaut alexander
gerst ein optimist das leben auf der
erde schon seit jahrmilliarden
überstanden der homo sapiens existiert
auch schon bei 100000 jahre
wir sind gute problem löse wir sind gute
strategie wir können mit den sich
verändernden umweltbedingungen umgehen
aber wir müssen natürlich auch schauen
dass wir unsere unsere umwelt unserem
planeten bewahren
das futur ii um wild denkanstöße liefern
abstrakte themen anschaulich und
anfassbar machen wie es ist wenn
maschinen unsere gedanken lesen können
das probiere ich hier aus das stirnband
liest man stress level rosa heißt ich
bin angespannt blau entspannt je wilder
es in meinem kopf zugeht desto unruhiger
das gekritzel auf der glasscheibe
ehrlich ich finde allein den gedanken
dass sie gerade in meiner gedankenwelt
gucken und sehen ob ich entspannt oder
gestresst bin ziemlich beunruhigend doch
wie wäre das nur ein gedanke und schon
ist der herd zu hause ganz sicher aus
das futur ii um wie viele es sein
medizin gegen technik ängste balsam für
die deutsche erfinder seele ansporn für
alle
man kann als einzelner sehr wohl etwas
bewirken durch sein verhalten gestaltet
man ob man will oder nicht zukunft mit
falls wir es vergeigen sollten mit
unserer zukunft diese pflanzen hier
wachsen auch auf verseuchten böden wohl
selbst dann noch wenn kein mensch mehr
da ist um sie zu gießen
dass die forschungsgruppe wahlen ein
neues politbarometer erstellt hat kam in
unserer sendung ja schon vor allerdings
nur ein kleiner teil davon und das ganze
bild zeigt ihn jetzt matthias fornoff
[Musik]
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
es war ein politisches beben mit ansage
der erfolg der fdp bei den
landtagswahlen im osten 30 jahre nach
dem fall der mauer hat in sachsen und
brandenburg rund jeder vierte die partei
vom rechten rand gewählt die mit dem
slogan geworben hat vollende die wende
bundesweit kommt die afg nur bei den
eigenen anhängern gut an
auf der beliebtheits skala von plus 5
bis minus 5 erreicht die afg einen
negativ wert von durchschnittlich minus
3,3 parteiübergreifend wird sie äußerst
schlecht bewertet das spektrum reicht
von minus 3,8 bei den unionsanhängern
bis minus 4,7 bei den grünen nur die afg
anhänger bewerten die partei mit 3,6
positiv sicherlich ein grund für die
ablehnung 80 prozent der befragten im
politbarometer sind überzeugt dass
rechtsextremes gedankengut in der afg
weit oder sehr weit verbreitet ist
nach einschätzungen der afg anhänger
haben 42 prozent die partei
hauptsächlich wegen ihrer politischen
forderungen gewählt nicht nur aus
protest mehr als drei viertel aller
befragten gehen dagegen von einer
denkzettelwahl aus nachdem die
machtverhältnisse in sachsen und
brandenburg ziemlich umgepflügt wurden
ist im bund der wunsch nach stabilität
deutlich gewachsen dass die
bundesregierung aus cdu/csu und spd bis
zur nächsten geplanten bundestagswahl
2021 halten wird glauben jetzt 72
prozent der befragten nur 22 prozent
rechnen mit einem vorzeitigen ende
im juni gingen nur 60 prozent vom
fortbestand der groko aus 34 prozent
hatten zweifel
im herbst will die koalition halbzeit
bilanz ziehen
die neue parteispitze wird innerhalb der
spd auch die einstellung zur
regierungskoalition beeinflussen
das rennen um den spd-vorsitz ist seit
dieser woche eröffnet sollte die spd
weiter mitregieren
42 prozent sagen ja die groko ist die
beste option jeder zweite allerdings ist
der ansicht für die spd wäre der gang in
die opposition besser bei den spd
anhängern ist das verhältnis umgekehrt
52 prozent bevorzugen das regieren 45
prozent die opposition diesmal punktet
die spd beim wähler und legt in der
sonntagsfrage wenn auch auf niedrigem
niveau zu ansonsten gibt es wenig
veränderungen
wenn am nächsten sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre käme die cdu csu auf 28 prozent
unverändert die spd legt auf 15 prozent
zu plus 2 die fdp bleibt bei 13 prozent
unverändert die fdp verliert etwas 6
prozent minus 1 die linke sieben
unverändert die grünen 24 - einst die
anderen parteien zusammen 7 prozent
unverändert der wunsch der wählerinnen
und wähler nach kontinuität hängt
offenbar auch mit der kanzlerin zusammen
eine große mehrheit von 73 prozent
findet es gut dass angela merkel bis zum
ende der legislaturperiode 2021
weitermachen will
besonders großen rückhalt bekommt sie
mit 88 prozent bei den eigenen
parteianhängern und mit 85 prozent bei
den anhängern der grünen nur die afg
anhänger sind mehrheitlich gegen sie in
der top ten der wichtigsten politiker
gibt es diesmal keine dramatischen
veränderungen auf der skala von +5 bis
-5 bleibt horst seehofer schlusslicht
etwas besser minus 0,5 vorletzter platz
für annegret kramp karrenbauer
verbessert minus 0,2 vor ihr ursula von
der leyen minus 0,1 eben
falls verbessert auf rang 7 markus söder
0,0 vor ihm christian lindner ebenfalls
0,0 beide leicht schlechter platz fünf
für jens spahn und verändert 0,3 davor
olaf scholz etwas besser 0,9 knapp vor
ihm heiko maas trotz leichter einbußen
0,9 auf dem zweiten platz robert habeck
etwas besser 1,5 und weiter auf platz
eins angela merkel mit gewinnen 1,7
das ist ihr bester wert in dieser
regierungszeit blicken wir noch ins
ausland der machtkampf um den dreck cit
hält diese woche europa in atem
welchen ausgang erwarten die deutschen
30 prozent rechnen derzeit mit einem
ungeordneten drexhage nur fünf prozent
hoffen noch auf einen geordneten
austritt
die mehrheit von 59 prozent geht von
einer weiteren verschiebung aus fest
steht die deutschen finden den austritt
der briten aus der eu mit großer
mehrheit schlecht spaltung statt einheit
eine gefahr die auch in deutschland
droht die polarisierung jedenfalls ist
im parteiensystem weit fortgeschritten
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
und auf heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer punkt
zdf.de vielen dank für ihr interesse
das nächste politbarometer gibt es dann
am 27 september
und hier geht es nach dem wetter weiter
mit maybrit illner ihnen noch einen
schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir schauen zurück
auf den august 2009 10 und weltweit war
der august der zweitwärmste ja und der
wärmste monate wärmster august monat
liegt gar nicht so weit zurück dass war
das jahr 2016
aber wie wirkt sich diese erwärmung
eigentlich auf das eis außen wir schauen
mal in die arktis auf den arktischen
ozean direkt das sehen sie hier
und diese orangene linie die zeigt
eigentlich die ausdehnung normalerweise
in einem august und hier ist mit einem
blick direkt erkennbar dass es deutlich
weniger als 35 prozent weniger als im
august ja und nicht nur die
eisausdehnung also die fläche wird
geringer sondern auch die dicke so aus
der vergangenheit schauen wir jetzt
wieder in die zukunft und da wird es an
den küsten regnen in der kommenden nacht
und das bei einem strammen westwind
teils stürmisch im süden gibt es auch
regen der lässt nach in der mitte klart
es auf
da wird es ordentlich kalt die
temperaturen sinken bis auf 2 grad
örtlich gibt es bodenfrost
im süden sind wir gerade zweistellig
teils bei zehn grad und auch an den
küsten bei zehn bis elf grad sonst meist
einstellige werte
warum gibt es viel sonnenschein in einem
streifen vom saarland über die mitte
nach osten hin
ja und im süden dominieren die wolken im
norden gibt es auch viele wolken an der
nordsee dazu viel regen mit kräftigem
südwestwind mit temperaturen in diesem
sonnigen bereich mit 18 bis 21 grad ganz
im süden sind es nur 14 grad die
nächsten tage gehen kühl weiter
samstag 14 bis 20 grad und viele schauer
und gewitter und so sieht dann auch das
wochenende und am montag aus ein schöner
abend